wouldn't society be better especially
America if you had to enlist in the
military if you had to live a life like
that it's a very good question take more
pride in our nation and like I I don't
think there'd be as much hate I don't
think there would be as much toxic like
toxic environment on social media if
everyone had to serve in the military
because you learn like you kind of learn
discipline you learn the value of life
some guys the majority of go to third
world countries you see what other
people are like yeah you there's huge
discipline you have to work as a team
yep you realize what matters yeah you're
not you know in your mom's basement
criticizing those who are doing things
that you would never think of doing yeah
you know like you don't see a lot of
military guys hating hating on the
Internet well I don't know I I do think
that's always been a contentious issue
and we did have a draft look up how long
we had a draft in this country and I
think after Vietnam was when things got
stopped right
yeah when Muhammad Ali up see how well
he yeah he had the balls that was a
pretty ballsy thing for him to do
hundred but but at the end of the day
the drought that draft came to an end
when the United States Armed Forces
moved to an all-volunteer military force
however the Selective Service System
remains in place as a contingency plan
many male citizens between the ages of
18 and 25 required register so that a
draft can be readily resumed if needed
there you go draft ends 19 after Vietnam
that's right yeah so so this country's
always had a very contentious issue in
terms of there was always the worry that
a standing army a standing army in this
country would be historically abused so
in throughout history when you had a
standing army you had an army that was
ready to go a charismatic leader would
come to power like Napoleon and take
control of that standing army to then
control the population the population
it's just what would happen yeah you
always have a charismatic dude Sherwood
who would figure out a way to control
the volunteers yeah everyone everyone
and still goes on this in this in the
world today and the United States would
that that was the large question but we
had to ultimately have a standing army
because we had
threats from the British we had to be a
yeah but we were surrounded by oceans so
we had the luxury of having time to deal
with that but but I think III do agree
that if you had a military draft I think
a lot of people would gain a great deal
from it especially young men who had all
that aggression anyway yeah and and and
and by the way also maybe it would also
when you get when you are put in the
military from saves the age of 18 to 20
what are you doing those years anyways
you're trouble trouble it keeps you out
of trouble probably but also you learn
kind of a foundation of how you should
kind of live the rest of your life
respect that worked well with others
working well with others being exposed
to like you said to other countries a
condition as a guy grew up all over the
world if everybody in this country would
just spend one month abroad anywhere
just to see how other people live we'd
have a very different foreign policy but
about first have you ever met like a
mill like a real military guy who's just
a tool I haven't I probably have come
from a military family yeah yeah I
haven't well one of their just you know
just like kind of guys yeah effort so
one of these I said to my dad after
after well I'm sure they're out there
I've never met him my father was a
marine and always talks about this and
one of the things I noticed about when I
went to Afghanistan with with Steve
Byrne and Duff Davidoff and Sam Tripoli
you know we went on that USA Oh tour was
amazing one of the things I notice about
being in a war zone was that it's all
about the dude or the gal next to you
you come last it's it's it's country its
its platoon you know it's outfit and
then it's ultimately you come last but
so when you see dudes in a war zone
everybody will say there are a bunch of
bags and a truck the one thing I noticed
is that they are they everybody helps
it's like you don't even think about
you're not getting your bag you're
getting other bags first yeah so
everything about that but coming from
Hollywood and I've been in Hollywood for
so long where it was all about you it's
all about narcissus it's just about you
know you are the center of your universe
because that's reward yeah in in the
military it's the exact opposite and
there's something very refreshing and
guys get a guising house get addicted to
that community that thing were your hall
and when you're in a war zone you're
always a
you have to rely on each other you
create real bonds in stress situation
and create what you actually produce
oxytocin which is a bonding chemical and
I say the close thing I've never been in
combat but the close thing would be you
fighting in the UFC guys go through this
weird experience that only you two can
go through I don't I'd love to see the
science behind that maybe there's there
I mean you release the same toxin you do
is nine toxins it's a it's a chemical so
it's a bonding capable on the kids about
bonding hormone called oxytocin that
assuming that woman there baby that's
right gotcha
and so I'm assuming you developed the
same release body when you go through
that stress even if the guy beat me up
say Travis Browne whoever it was there
I've go in the back and there was no
anger there's no resentment well think
about I go we both went but think about
you and I like like think about the bond
like of starting out with the with Joe
when we Roman told you to stop fighting
yeah the decision to keep doing the
podcast to let it out that [ __ ] is all
that stuff's stressful when it's
happening it's not pleasant and there
was a lot of unknown with us about when
I called you and the guy got us kicked
out of Fox remember yeah a lot of it's
on me call browsing well remember that
well I might have made some enemies
we've been locked out of our we got
locked out we just couldn't even go into
the building oh we gotta figure some out
man you're like oh well yeah I guess
we'll be just our ride or die here here
we go yeah man so I do think that a
drive always kind of felt like a draft
but again good nation cancer right
you're making you're also forcing people
you know to join government military
outfit at the same time look at the way
like those countries have a draft
most countries have a draft but also
like the way our societies go to switch
through the younger generation ain't
good like look out toxic social medias
hmm it's variable I don't know that
being in the military would I do think
that a lot of these moms saying we give
them perspective yeah I do think a lot
of people from the age of 18
- you know somebody said if you want to
get rid of all the crime in the country
all you got to do is just take every
fourteen-year-old boy and keep him in
basically a military like outfit from 14
to 20 you'll have zero violent crime
because that's that's it that's the age
that so I promise ain't the answer I'm
saying be up so you can't we're not
gonna do that
I don't think then here's the thing
let's say we go to war with Iraq which
we might get strem stupid enough Iran
Iran let's say we're able to do that to
run let's say we're gonna do that and
your son was a disaster and your son was
a teen yeah yeah I'm like sorry he's in
the draft that but no he's not well so
that was that was tough for that be if
that's your kid that was the scarring of
Vietnam where so many people came back
and they didn't even know where it was
on the map and they went I'm going to
Vietnam and those guys that went when we
lose 54,000 Tyson and and a lot of them
came back weren't the same anymore and
we just we like and then we were like
but wait it didn't do anything oh wait
the North invaded the South in this
economy's country and wait you guys told
us that we had to stop we had to stop
this domino effect so the idea do you
know yeah we have stopped the domino
effect is the world's being taken over
by communists so we don't stop them here
we did it in Lebanon we did in Greece so
now we got to do it again in Vietnam we
did it we did in Korea we start we did
it in North and vs South Korea we had to
whether there's a big outcry right like
they don't want that's why Vietnam was
so well the things that we were winning
the war I mean did the fact that matters
the US military fought very well in
Vietnam and the Tet Offensive was
actually a huge success by America it
was a huge success when the Viet Cong
tried to take over but but when you saw
it on camera when you saw it on camera
it looked like we got our asses kicked
and it changed the way the American
public looked at the war but so who's
hurting point was broadcasting that
because if it was coming for Walter
Cronkite but why people why broadcast us
losing like why not paint the picture
like we're wasn't that we were losing
but what made what made news was the
sensational stuff the pictures of a girl
on fire huh after a napalm attack she's
running toward the camera Americans went
what the [ __ ] is what are we seeing the
the caskets and seeing the military the
young man
who are wounded horribly and killed that
was that came into American living rooms
and it and it sparked an Intel it
sparked massive protest was the first
time Hey yeah World War two not really
forties you know that's like in
broadcast well remembers on the rain and
remember in World War two the
fundamental difference was that we were
flying enemy we were fighting the
Japanese and Germans who would the
Japanese had attacked us they had
attacked us look at that look at that
misery I don't see those Jim it's
changed you ever think about going the
military no the reason I'm in this
country is because of that reason well
parents didn't want me to go to military
yeah oh because in Korea you have to
enlist yeah my dad loves me did like two
years yeah I think hard service in a
military the Korean men are the Koreans
are very hard men the code the culture
expects hardness out of their men you
just know that there are tough women
don't have to do anything on it the
Korean Tigers who fought in Vietnam were
kuvira came they were feared they they
were pretty badass the guys I know who
served in Vietnam said that the the
people that they thought could endure
the most the biggest hardship with the
Koreans they were just like the Korean
Tigers were just like [ __ ] they blew
their mind they were just like they were
all like all like Navy SEALs why would I
give that to you as a gift it's a gift